so I don't know what to tell this
[ __ ] so I just tell him
greetings from podcast available the
Church of what's happening now is
brought to you by helix sleep listen a
lot of things have been keep long with
Joey at night lately you know this has
been a tough period for a lot of people
but with my sleep apnea sometimes I can
get this lis but I'd miss leaping
alright but something came into my life
that has changed my sleep completely
helix sleep the best mattress is out
there personalized mattress is made in
the USA they deliberate the house you
put in the garage you take off the old
mattress you put the new mattress on the
bed let it unfold you can't even believe
it's a mattress when you get in the
[ __ ] mail you let it unfold and all
sudden it shapes you sleep on in
two-three minutes by the third night you
think you're sleeping in God's [ __ ]
hands that's how comfortable it is you
wake up feeling like a [ __ ] soldier a
debt a little CBD line and then [ __ ]
miss forget about it nobody's better
than you so do me a favor all that
matches and pillows that ship straight
to your door and they do totally contact
free delivery and right now you got
nothing to do so why not go to helix
sleep calm slash Church and use uncle
Joey's 100 nights asleep on trial what
that means is you got a hundred nights
if you don't like it send it back
nobody knows nothing Heelys has a great
deal for the church family you ready two
hundred dollars off all mattresses and
if you order a matches you get two free
helix pillows for free at helix comm
slash church again that's helix dot-com
slash Church helix dot-com slash Church
I'm gonna Saviour up to two and log off
your favorite mattress and you're gonna
sleep tight knowing uncle Joey sent you
that's it and that's that right take
this [ __ ] meal leaf
[Music]
Church
[Music]
one day
25th
Memorial Day it's don't feel like one
more old days with a memorial for the
last two and a half [ __ ] months we've
been [ __ ] dead but don't worry about
that it's a whole new week whatever
happened last week happened last week
this week is this week and remember just
because you didn't suck your dick nine
months ago you ain't out of the game
Brent this dude call up she might say
yes this time I'm saying you never know
people change
it's been great I feel better I'm a
hundred percent better than uh when this
pandemic started whatever little [ __ ]
you want to call this thing I'm still
wearing my mask I still have a little
bit of fear but I'm okay you can hear it
in my voice you could see it in my
mannerisms uh like I told you guys the
beginning there was gonna be a silver
lining to this and for me there was I
had people send me hate mail what I said
this what do you mean silver lining I
lost my job watch.watch is gonna be a
silver lining and there has been for a
few people if there hasn't been wants me
for you yet it's coming you just haven't
looked oh you haven't tried hard enough
when I was doing the the early read for
the [ __ ] my bookie I said OTB I don't
even know ODB exists in New York anymore
but ot B's were a [ __ ] blast and I
was a kid because it was one on 178
Street and suppose the bus landed from
Fort Lee and Port Authority sees me they
go outside and freeze to death or kill
time i lo t be how about go on then but
you know that like two hours across the
board on a horse but you didn't go there
to win you went there for the
entertainment you went there to see the
pickpockets you went to see the chicks
trying to hustle a [ __ ] guys trying
to cheat in on bets guys trying to stack
on a horse
so they've met the other horse it's a
tenant and then the room is as big as
you know it's like four or five of these
offices and that's how big you got 90
people in there I don't think they're
around no more because they would just
be [ __ ] a Chinese sword in the floor
dead from Kovac but [ __ ] that ODB's
used to be a lot of fun anyway it's been
an interesting week it's been an
interesting month you have the day off
today big [ __ ] deal
had the day off for the last two and a
half months like they're doing us a
favor
well my wife told me Friday Mercy's got
no school on Monday great what's the
difference what's the [ __ ] difference
we've had it for the last two and a half
months - I was a computer [ __ ]
teaching and the rest of the day I gotta
wear a [ __ ] hat on and play assistant
to assistant to the assistant to the
assistant principal excuse me I'm trying
to get the joint going to get this
[ __ ] atmosphere going you know I'm
saying there's a church what's happened
now on the Monday morning you show up
with [ __ ] gloom and doom you got your
pockets upside down and you're depressed
eight so is everybody else who's got a
stick and go around the corner what do
you want from me having fun well you
know fun is free you do know that people
going to the beach is free going to a
park and bringing a bologna sandwich a
monster Maya that's free vitamin D is
free summer you decide to place for
vitamin D doesn't exist go [ __ ] yourself
we got a [ __ ] a tanning bed what
white lightnin sat in front of it but
you're outside don't enjoy I yell at me
every day for these don't go out of the
house I don't know what he has of the
house what he's guarding over there if
he's got one he's walking when you're
not hiding Steve you're walking you know
something interesting happened this week
that people are blown away about doesn't
blow me away
cuz I've been friends with the guy
[ __ ] ever and I could tell the guys
always played outside his own realm and
that's a Spotify but the Joe Rogan
podcast and you know people been hitting
me up pros and cons I don't know
anything about the business and how it
works now it's gonna affect it I know
that how Conor McGregor's say sells out
Las Vegas and you know kind of McGregor
doesn't saw the UFC he sells out Las
Vegas Joe Rogan has the same effect on
people with his products whenever he
pushes I mean he can't pick a winner
look at Bernie Sanders he picked Bernie
Bernie almost killed himself together
you can't go well as well as he can't
pick UFC fighters either but he's [ __ ]
knowledgeable he's smart as [ __ ] and
he's interesting he's got a great
podcast but the reason why that happened
is simply because he's always thought
outside the comedy box and that's the
greatest gift that I've got from him
that well most people were doing these
world tours you never see [ __ ] Joe
doing world tours nothing like that he
keeps everything simple I have made my
business plan part of how Joe I watch
with Joe's doing I see what you know
Sagar is doing I see with all the guys
that are better than me doing I see what
Bill burr is doing and you take a little
bit from each of their styles
you know whether it be their podcast and
stand-up I'm not saying the steel you
don't steal nothing you look at what
they're doing it's working for them and
you copy that [ __ ] business pattern
you know I'm not saying Spotify is only
give me money money spot if I don't even
know what the [ __ ] I am and I don't want
Spotify is another [ __ ] I am I just want
you to know who the [ __ ] I am
and that's all that matters to me but
it's just so weird how Joe has been
working straight like nobody just gives
you anything American people everybody
thinks the blue bird that happened it
shows up at your door [ __ ] Joe Rock
Rogan he's lucky no man Joe goes down
there five days a week and there's four
podcast a week he works out five days a
week he writes on the weekend he's
always got something with his girls you
know it's a non-stop world for Joe with
Joe doesn't one day you guys doing one
week it's the same with me what I do in
one morning some people doing a [ __ ]
week because you put the [ __ ] work in
it's the language that saying up years
ago keep showing up it was a picture Joe
wrote and he kept showing up I have the
utmost respect for Joe Rogan and it
started 20 years ago when he was on news
radio when he'd shoot all [ __ ] day
and then still go and get a $15.00 spot
at 12 o'clock following [ __ ] Paul
Mooney or something like that
and I would sit there and all and say
that's the point to get on a TV show why
would you come down here no
the point is to be the best stand-up you
can and then he [ __ ] started with the
podcast and I think people were doing at
first but he doing it late not on the
road and I'm gonna mean are real
paranoid at first we wouldn't smoke dope
on the camera and stuff we were really
scared but he had this idea 10 11 years
ago and nobody was thinking about it and
then when I'm off quit comedy he talked
me into doing a podcast with Felicia so
he knew something was up and I told the
story by mugging a hooker and here we
are [ __ ] seven eight years later
still podcasting so there's something to
it I follow his lead on a lot of things
I follow his lead on a lot of things I
follow Bill Birds lead on a lot of
things but don't ever forget like that
since I started doing this podcast and
will tell you I've seen podcasts come
and go because people's expectations are
not real they're not and this is what
everything anymore somebody try
something they get into a form once it's
over that said I was too hard no nothing
is gonna be easy what do you think he
just went walking on then they gotta
[ __ ] pay you millions of dollars now
you gotta put the time and that's why
I've said since day one to people
punching in is very important punching
in is doing anything that'll make you
better and sacrificing it when your
girlfriend calls you and it says to you
oh we're gonna go over to Mildred's and
have some mimosas who gives the
Frenchman's [ __ ] I want them um what
isn't my most to do to you nothing gives
you a [ __ ] headache and champagne
when I was juice you gotta do 10 miles
on the [ __ ] treadmill next day to
burn off the sugar no I must stay on the
right calmly sacrifice Joe has
sacrificed ton you know he didn't just
become the UFC announcer did you know
that or did you just they just called
him at home one day and said Joe why
should I be the announcer he was doing
news radio he was a fan he picked up the
phone and he called Dana White and he
offered to do what we're doing for free
how many people willing to do that are
you would you do that right now at this
time would you walk into a store
tomorrow if your family needed food and
go
going to work for free to show you how
hard I work look at that beat right
there
I'll work that [ __ ] by three
could would you do that do you have the
[ __ ] balls to do that that's what I'm
saying
he had the balls he made the call nice
get the UFC paying him he's got twenty
five thousand people paying him now he's
got spot upon for I paying him but don't
ever think at one point his line that
that kid even [ __ ] sleeps you know
when he did that
October's over October he put up his
results and if you look at his sleep his
sleeping is the worst thing yes he
sleeps in six hours a night you know why
cuz he's always going he's always
thinking he writes comedy you know so
don't it just didn't happen that Joe
lucked out they could have given it to
Marc Maron they could've given it to
Bill burr they could've give him that
deal to a thousand other people not
really Kevin Hart Gabriel is in the same
round Whitney Cummings but Rogan brings
something extra with him you know what
that is he has a voice and that voice
carries see the certain people that do
podcasts and they do podcasts free to
let you hear what they want you to hear
I don't give a [ __ ] what the [ __ ] you
hear for me I'm gonna tell you what I
want to tell you whether you like it or
not if you don't like it move on this
off the [ __ ] podcast but this is a
podcast of truth where I tell you the
[ __ ] truth it's Monday what do you
want to do you want me to come away with
a bunch of [ __ ] stories on [ __ ]
Monday no I tell you the truth this
didn't happen to Joe overnight because
he's Joe this happened because it's 30
years of grinding every day asking
questions hey I'm telling you this time
as I put on one of his podcast and he's
got one of those crazy people on that I
wanna watch that either well for the
most part he's got a lot of great guests
on that and he gets to some of the best
guests I've seen on there
Rhonda Patrick the guy from [ __ ]
Aerosmith was great [ __ ] the guy from
sleep the reason why I sleep as well as
I do when I focus on it was because of
that book so by him getting this money
from whatever just you know don't sit
there and say he's the luckiest guy in
the world
and there's a second point I want
made for this story to last couple of
weeks the agents have been calling you
you know offering your deals these
people want to lend you money to send
you on the road and do all this [ __ ]
this just told us to show you how good
Joe and his management team are they
work outside the box
comedy is great but comedy right now is
being worked inside a box this is what I
don't agree with it this is why I wasn't
going on the road as everybody else I
don't like how it's worth it's worked
inside a box people work outside the box
are enjoying it more Joe works outside
the box he enjoys it more that's why I
copy his style he works outside the box
I've been watching that for 20 years the
managing style of his manager so in my
mind I'm my own [ __ ] manager I should
be doing what he does which I do I look
at things you know I'm an econ major I
think I'll have a degree for he can't
but I gotta [ __ ] master's degree in
Street [ __ ] math and you don't gonna
beat me on that you know I'm saying I
know numbers and you look at numbers and
it's just not working a lot of the user
going through all right thing right now
and I'm telling you that this is the
time to do what you all you wanted to do
[ __ ] with your wife Dinks and your
father or uncle you got laid off you get
unemployment you want to play the tuba
this is the time go to a pawn shop
get a [ __ ] too cold the test it
before you buy the [ __ ] her and stop
playing the - but everybody has a dream
go for your [ __ ] dream this is what
this was for this was not a [ __ ]
thing from China and Trump before this
was a sign to wake us up to wake you up
that you should be doing more to wake us
up now we could be doing a little better
we could be better people to our friends
we could be better friends to our
friends we could be better brothers to
our brothers would be better sons we
could be better there's so many things
that I've gotten from this you know when
this first started like two weeks after
the start I saw a thing that said
domestic violence is up I love my wife
but there's some nights when I'm anxiety
I just want to kick her like a meals and
lights because she sees I'm
xiety and I'm [ __ ] fading away and
you know from 7:30 to 8:00 I have a
rough time so I try to breathe it out
and like I'll ask her a question just to
deter her and then she'll just go on
with the story
and once the politics comes out my
anxiety goes up a different level but
you know what I gotta be after you guys
during this time I've learned to love my
wife a lot more I saw the reasons I saw
the things in my life and my wife that
made me fall in love with her in the
first place I saw where my weaknesses
were
you know I've been wanting to get off
the road the two [ __ ] years guys but
two years I'm going to get off the road
write this book so I can get this out
and now I have the opportunity and
that's why I read their outline every
day or I spoke to one of the guys in the
office there Dana gave me an idea to
start taping and listening to myself so
I did that three times already just to
see how creepy that is that's not even
listening to a stand-up set so there's
no pressure okay I'm just listening to
his stories so that's been working out
for me so and again and the bike riding
for you guys who've been sending me
emails I just mention you know every
time I mention something on here lightly
you guys bombard me with stuff and I
gotta be honest a it doesn't bother me
at all
because I learned a lot of stuff you
guys sent me some bike stuff I did not
know about in fact it was a guy was like
a 61 year old bike ride that sent me
like a little workout to do nice like
just to do like in tool training with
weights that you could do it with a bite
too
you know so there's uh I started riding
the bike I might know why nobody the
first dad did one minute and I thought
my body was gonna break down I couldn't
even control the handlebars and I went
to five minutes ten minutes and I'm up
to thirty five [ __ ] minutes so and
I've been riding every day yeah thank
you
no no you've been walking - listen man
it's just time to do different [ __ ] I'm
happy that I don't have to go on the
road I'm happy that and guess what else
I'm writing jokes again I've written a
few [ __ ] pretty good [ __ ] jokes
and
it's just jokes are they ready for the
stage not at all I'm happy with them
because I'm writing at least so let me
tell you something I thank you guys
because you have been my therapist or
all this you have forced me to get out
of the house you have for I moved for
one of the one of the zooms I put in my
house and it felt great but it didn't
feel good because when I go to work I
want to go to work you know when I leave
the house when I'm at home I'm daddy I
can't be daddy I'm a [ __ ] computer
room yelling and screaming talking to a
fellow but in my office I could be
[ __ ] daddy did I tell you something
man
what's that the weirdest [ __ ] thing
so you had that come in here I clean
around the time the time sometimes don't
come in and wipe down the table the
thing if I know I'm coming here my
daughter in the afternoon I'll come here
in the morning and wipe everything down
air it out with some music
yeah dad was sitting there talking to
mercy she was in the counter here
sucking a milkshake
oh this is tremendous is refill this is
again from urban trees whatever the [ __ ]
they got 30% that's what they give me I
walk in there they just give me a back
that's it here you go smoke this take
this and I had to do what they tell me
I'm like Rage Against the Machine I do
what they tell me
anyway I come in here the other day so
when we do our podcast she sits in my
chair and I tape it from over there and
I'm looking bar the cups over here on
the floor and I hit the bong and stuff
so she wouldn't see it and I don't know
what happened you didn't see me the
other day all right without Berto crane
called the other day cuz he's gonna be
on later this week then when I was
stolen from on the couch I don't know if
you noticed I pick something up
no I didn't I found the men's wallet
with no ID in it just a card and three
condoms
you found my stash crazy I know it's not
your stash
yeah you haven't even put on a condom
since they were [ __ ] white like
coloring their thing you dicks like a
boys last time you put a poor condom
only the last time I had sex which was
seven eight months ago probably yeah in
the last year are you feeling you ready
to bust I'm ready to call one of these
freaks there's no free to go
I'm supposed to trust me I'm supposed to
be on lockdown and any the ones that I
could call you know the couple that I
could call I don't want to call them
Melissa that were that right now is when
the chick this as lonely as she can't a
chick that said no to you now we'll say
yes to you just for a simple bike ride
cuz they're lonely yeah but you gotta
borrow these woman now I was going to
bother them they've had it they've been
through eight weeks of being alone
they'll do anything I'll let you like
that [ __ ] on fire and I'll do anything
right now I'm great they're lonely you
gotta find yourself a [ __ ] woman wait
that's it the party's over
stop blaming it on I'm gonna lose weight
first just go out and find the [ __ ]
woman there's women that like your
chubby handsome juice and your water
phone final I wonder how long those
crimes at limit though I'm trying to
think if we could you know no the funny
thing was when I found the condoms I
looked at him in the car only one name
but I couldn't blame just her because
other people have sat down like I said
my daughter sits there and the chick
that came when dbo the chick that came
with Tyson a lot of people at her side
of that chair so I don't know who the
[ __ ] would have showed up here with
three condoms and they're the good ones
too and that's the only thing they had
in there is carnauba that's it no money
no ID no nothing a wallet ten like a
men's closed wallet a [ __ ] hotel card
from the Harvard hotel see with a
harvard hotel is if there's a Harvard
hotel I never get hurt and three cons
and then we're gonna go [ __ ]
I'm mad at nobody it's just it's really
I'm not saying that it bothered me it's
like who the [ __ ] was going somewhere
after this [ __ ] condom see it yeah
where the [ __ ] is the Harvard hotels
around here is [ __ ] yeah it's what
Hollywood over there you go there you go
so what a [ __ ] about it's not a nice
place no holy moly
I love everything that we've had in here
that's like the same this thing we found
drugs in here I've drawn a ton of [ __ ]
in here
I came to say this [ __ ] I found here
that I found on that side when people
sit there it's [ __ ] embarrassing but
who gives a Frenchman's [ __ ] it's
[ __ ] Monday [ __ ] alright
listen this thing is almost over I mean
they extended here till July 4th Orange
County is opening up next week San
Bernardino County is opening up next
week and we're all gonna be fine you
know last night two nights ago I went to
the weed store and they were the the
Chinese girl wasn't at the counter they
were really pretty Chinese girl at the
counter at urban trees and I went and it
was the big black security guard then I
looked around it was the manager that
was working and there was one other
employee and I know what's going on and
he doesn't man has been [ __ ] dead I
go what do you mean daddy goes dead
since like the [ __ ] tent businesses
dropped like [ __ ] 60% and that's what
I said I said this won't take people to
write two checks to realize where they
really are a lot of people didn't get
unemployment and now they gotta write
June checks yeah I still haven't gotten
the stimulus no you're not getting [ __ ]
I know three people who are moving on
their apartments either into their car a
friend's basement or into their business
three friends right now for June first I
have another friend I've been talking
him into leaving cuz he pays too high
ever rent here
and him and his wife leave anyway for
the summer I might put your [ __ ] in the
storage get the [ __ ] out of here
save that money from that rent and when
you come back the rents will be that
much cheaper if you come back all right
if you want to come back if you don't
want to come back and stay in DC I don't
blame you a lot of people this has
already started here in Los Angeles
people if you don't know it and it's at
that's starting in New York to New
Yorkers that are listening they'll tell
you the same people moving out of
buildings and into houses they don't
want to be involved in this no more
they don't want this Kotak they don't
ever want to be in this position again
this is gonna change people like I said
you know right now people don't start
looking at their savings their
retirement funds you know what if this
only what if we only get a month and a
half of freedom again and they lock this
back up in October again cuz it comes
back with the flu season twice as hard
so hey listen people scared I don't
blame you right meditate do everything
you can to give you a peace of mind if
you feel uncomfortable being somewhere
get the [ __ ] out hey listen man I
watched them last month as they were
walking into the Ford plant and people
were saying we're not ready yet they
know and sure enough they had to reclose
it the next day because they had six
cases in Detroit we're not ready for a
lot of things yet and one thing we're
never gonna do is social distance so
we're never going it's it's impossible
it's impossible are you gonna cactus
you've been to cactus before thinking go
on a cactus in ordering all right where
the waitresses where the chick is the
two cooks where you are in the scheme of
thing you know
well I think if you have change like
every like everything we talked about
flights the other day how how like you
can't go in there
because people like people that I'll
clean the planes because people get
angry about it like I think it's gonna
be very interesting like Oh like yeah
there might not be as messy as a
restaurant but there might be more
restaurants or it's more
you don't think so no how they don't
know you have any restaurant you're
about to close oh yeah all the way over
and we'll be done
do you know how many restaurants are
gonna be closed right now
have you taken a right to Hollywood
ladies I have been always like one take
a ride sometime and see what's going out
there in the real world go to Melrose
and look at those restaurants make that
make an estimate yeah head of what that
pain for rent at that place and what
they're losing every month and you ask
yourself are they gonna be open in July
who's gonna open any July July for it
you're opening up and dead to death it's
picnic season it's beach season ain't
nobody gonna Beverly Hills eat no [ __ ]
sandwich and it doesn't fill your
vacation like it sure it should fill
your vacation but does it no it's not
it's not a vacation this is not a
[ __ ] vacation there's a pandemic
going on in your head this life is
always a [ __ ] vacation it's a
vacation but this ain't a vacation
people are [ __ ] hurting right now and
people know it this is no time but
there's no vacation this is a [ __ ]
this is a pandemic that if you make the
wrong move you can end up in a hospital
yeah you know it's under a hundred
deaths in New York and it's under a
hundred deaths in LA and that's because
we've been staying in and we've been
vigilant but yes a Saturday I want to
give a shout out real quick to my man uh
John Buscemi from paulie's deli you know
why because that guy opened up a deli he
sent us a bunch of food he had so much
success in Beverly Hills then he opened
up another deli downtown and he called
me a couple days ago Negroes I wanted to
send you and Lee some food and I go
that's unnecessary if you see the size
of me and we we don't need food and he
goes nah because I I've been donating to
all these different causes and you know
whatever so I really want to give him a
shout-out it's not a sponsor it's
nothing like that go down there they
make great sandwiches they got one of
the best spicy Italians you've ever
[ __ ] had in your life so
I just wanted to throw that in real
quick you know uh there's not gonna be a
lot of restaurants left if you go around
now you could [ __ ] see like right now
restaurants are doing it's a three-man
operation all right maybe a four-man
with a dishwasher dead just bring it
it's it's like it's like selling
wholesale you're not making a profit but
at least you're generating money to come
through you're not totally there's no
money on through there's comedians that
I'm not making a dollar that their whole
income comes from touring and merch on
the road they don't have a merge button
on their website they're gonna suffer
guys like me and who broke it up into
podcasting t-shirts on the web you know
a little bit of comedy I never really
sank all my eggs in any of these three
things
it was various things plus I'm working
on the writing so by me working on the
other things and making money it pays me
to write even if it's ten bucks an hour
that's how I look at it for right now at
least I'm getting paid ten bucks an hour
to write so it's how you look at things
this was never a vacation that was the
wrong attitude to take this was
something to look at for two weeks see
what was going on and once you decided
that we weren't gonna go to work because
I knew this in the beginning I've been
saying this and not an icon in an on a
conspiracy Lu a theory level I just knew
there was something they weren't telling
us
I told lawyer you guys to get your money
back I told more you guys all this this
is just from living life why take a
chance
why have your money out there why do all
these things I told you [ __ ]
that things are gonna change and I told
happy is to get a job cannot wait for
unemployment because they're gonna be
six weeks behind there's people who
still haven't heard from unemployment
like I don't know what happened you know
what happened you [ __ ] up you should
have gone on to stock shelves and by now
you would have had your unemployment
they need to quit the stock Michels
my friend taught me right out where
they're only paying 1250 what else are
you doing at night you staying in the
[ __ ] house all day right I would die
fine a stay home all day and add
somebody got 11 o'clock and they paid
time and a half for overtime [ __ ] you I
put two [ __ ] mask on and yell at
people they stay the [ __ ] away from me
change my gloves you go home you know
this certain precautions that can be
taken if you really wanted to make this
happen yes this started as a limbo and
then it became a mourning we got we were
all confused because we started mourning
the death of our own lives the death of
our own lives arena shows basketball
games things that might not come back
the same way you know jiu-jitsu what is
the fate of jiu-jitsu you know that's
one of the questions I'm dying to ask
Alberto on [ __ ] Wednesday oh yeah you
know it's opposite of social distancing
are we gonna be able to go to a
restaurant now and there has to be a
table in between you do do I always said
that there was gonna be a pay cut
involved here there's gonna have to be
paid cuts because I can't book every
hotel room now I gotta have a real hotel
room open in the middle so there's so
many things that are gonna come from
this that people have to adjust you know
comedy clubs
any day now you're gonna start hearing
comedy clubs just shut down because they
know it they know it themselves they're
gonna open up in June June is not timely
season especially this gym where there's
no money people are barely keeping
together right now financially so and
that's a fact right now people are
barely keeping it together you one of
those people and the heart goes out to
you I hope that you can find a way to uh
to take care of that you know there's
your family you have so many people out
there there's so many people willing to
help that it's ridiculous I mean me and
Steve Simone trade-off recipe
we trade off food you know it's it's
been for me it's been a great experience
I wanted to break from stand-up I wanted
to this in fact you know there was no
way I could call my agent and say I'm
taking eight months off because he would
have started calling me after three
weeks hey these people offering you this
what do you think come on come on come
on do you really want how you stole you
know now they can't call me and say
nothing
this has really given me a breather
after 29 [ __ ] years and not just a
tiptoe to the park 29 years this has
been hard you know I had the opposite of
the Rogen effect even though we both put
in the same work I've done worse work
because I didn't have a manager that he
had I'm not blaming his success on his
manager Rogen is a hard worker
and he [ __ ] deserves everything he
gets but he's got the best manager in
the business that worked outside the box
so whatever you're doing right now in
your life if it's not working to the
utmost maybe you're not working a little
bit outside the box
I believe in outside the box is nothing
wrong with working outside the [ __ ]
box give it a try maybe you'll make 110
million dollar deal with [ __ ] Spotify
what do you know what I know it's Monday
Memorial Day we got another month of
this and we're gonna make it you're
gonna make it why cuz your uncle [ __ ]
Joey said you're gonna make it that's
why one more [ __ ] month of this Li
right or - well I I didn't know was in
July 4th I was at the end of July July
4th is no official for California please
I didn't say that
July 4th is what the [ __ ] these humps to
say yeah I mean I I hope so I hope so I
think do what people are going crazy
right the thing that I'm glad I got
extended a little bit at least because
they were talking about opening up now
I'm in May and that scared me I don't
think they were ready I don't think
we're ready and you know what but people
are broke I went last night about 5:00
if I went to the weed store like I said
he told me business was down he said the
guy on the corner of the spaghetti
restaurant thinking a lot chicken
parmesan sandwich all is dead down I
said at the part and the YMCA parking
lot and I stretched I opened up my trunk
I did some kettlebells and I watch
people going by and there weren't too
many people at the park yesterday and
what that tells me is that the money
issue is now coming in now it's where
the money's coming in now is where
people are really starting to sweat it
out you know I mean yesterday the
[ __ ] roads were bad it's supposed to
be it looks at two weeks ago that were
yelling and screaming because they
wanted the beaches open now they can't
[ __ ] nobody was I went to the beach
twice last week
nobody was at the beach they just wanted
the beaches open right people don't want
to be told what to do it they just
wanted the beach is open and that's it
and that's that man that's a [ __ ]
Monday morning for you I know you got oh
you got no barbecues to go to you got no
[ __ ] no nothing to go to today you
can probably have a little Sun with your
family but I don't trust anything over
six
I really don't yeah but it also I think
I think it'll teach you for me I'm
always someone who likes smaller events
but there must be people who like big
events but ya have to three people over
get a steak or get make a couple hot
dogs and a couple burgers have a have a
cold beer and watch an old movie it's
not the same but it's awesome
I'm talking a remote place go meet find
a [ __ ] palm tree where you're outside
I don't trust it aside yet that's why
they haven't done anything inside yet
that letting you do [ __ ] but there's a
there has to be outside yeah you know
when you go anywhere on to hung all
those restaurants they make you wait
outside they make you wait hey the nine
feet they doing it right and [ __ ]
right there I'm a little [ __ ] for
hunger there oh no they it is in the
same thing with you they don't want
people saying they got sick here like
that
Hair Stylist in Missouri 150 people say
it would destroy me of you sat across
from me right now I'd rather talk to you
for now and try to entertain you and try
to get somebody [ __ ] sick right now
you know I'm used to Lily's used to me I
know he had it I know I got it we just
weren't symptomatic something that
happened I don't even know what
symptomatic means I'm just saying I know
something happened here cuz I had a
weird feeling at it back aches and [ __ ]
so somewhere along the line it just
[ __ ] came and mother [ __ ] went but
uh listen you know right now this is
what this was for this was not a
vacation this was a time to rebuild
yourself I'm gonna show this six million
dollar man this is what this is this is
for you to look from within and go where
the [ __ ] was I slipping where the [ __ ]
was I slipping at work maybe in this
time I give up smoking dope maybe it is
time I give up eating these pills maybe
it is time I give up this maybe it's
time I go to the gym more Americans and
get healthier never more American look
at themselves and now they know that
underlying effects attracts this disease
more than looking you can't find the
kettlebell online you can't find the
combat online you can't find weights on
what the [ __ ] bike store had [ __ ]
lists because yes it was boring but
people on the people are now knowing
those underlying conditions can kill you
so we're trying to improve those
underlying conditions you know I give I
tap my hot on every day the dean del Rey
he got diabetes on a Tuesday and Tuesday
night he was a changed man
I talked to Dean every night and I goof
on him but do we have tonight that
better chicken you know you know a
chicken layer with no sugar or whatever
but he sticks to it he walked seven
miles a [ __ ] nine every night that's
what you need to do to lower that
I'm petrified of diabetes so for me it's
heavy lifting and now I've included the
bicycle is no more boxing even though I
did go to the park this weekend hit the
mitts with a friend of mine I double
mask just to take my fear down I wanted
to
take my fear down I'm trying to work on
my fears of being in public I just don't
want to walk out in front of 50 people
in bread in two months and [ __ ] have
a nervous breakdown on stage that's my
biggest [ __ ] fear so like I've been
woloson like now I go to Walgreens at 12
and I see if there's five people you're
I'm saying how I feel with five people
and trust me nobody's social distancing
some people really really really try I
really try as you could tell I [ __ ]
hate zoom and I had to go to zoom
because I can't do 40 minutes or an hour
talking with a [ __ ] face mask on get
out bill for that [ __ ] just mime time
it's a [ __ ] nightmare your mouth feel
like that Anthony got your teeth the
fallin out of your [ __ ] mouth after I
now but that's it man it's Memorial Day
and two and a half months ago you didn't
think you could you didn't know what to
think and look over at already it's
Memorial Day look where this country is
gone to look over at but you know what's
most important we're still [ __ ] him
and we're still ticking and V is still
up in Toronto and Lingus and who he
spooky still in Austin and and you know
my man is Joey what's his name Maurice
your Alvarado is still stuck selling
whatever spoons I'm doing Cassius Morris
one day this week
life goes on guys life goes on you have
to look at this see how it will affect
you and your family what needs to be
done so you don't get it and move
forward and that's it don't look back
this is just a bump in the [ __ ] road
for some people for a guy like me
there's a bump in the road for some
people this could be life-changing this
people were killing themselves my heart
goes out to them
you know loneliness shouldn't be that
bad but again I was raised in the only
child I've been with prison I can't sit
against that wall all [ __ ] day and
stare it if I have to because I got a
parade going on to my hands that's where
I look out over a lot of other people so
but anyway I'm happy I'm happy you're
here I'm happy you still supporting the
podcast
I'm happy that you gotta have a great
Memorial Day and hey it's all uphill for
me if you really think about it that's
it you did your toughest spots you went
through your toughest spots now it's
just climbing climbing climbing
maintaining and once they open BAM
you're there with a new attitude
a new outlook new energy new motivation
and inspired because you've seen where
you could end up you've seen how many
people lose now sees you look at people
there's a lot of people worse off than
you so stop feeling sorry for yourself
but on your big-boy pants grab your [ __ ]
salute the [ __ ] flag and you're an
American you know me an American today
and you're gonna be an American next
year and what we specialize in is making
[ __ ] comebacks
that's what we specialize in in America
is designing to come back all right so
get it together stop your [ __ ]
whining we're here we're queer what
dates I got no dates I'm not going
nowhere I'm making you [ __ ]
we're all in county jail for the next
month and a half but once everything
gets cleaned up with the airports and
the planes and health and all this [ __ ]
I'm gonna be in all your [ __ ]
home town laying it down even I don't
care if I die I'm [ __ ] stage I'm going
out there to [ __ ] rocking you guys
know when I get up there I don't give a
[ __ ] so thank you very much for
listening really quick before we cut it
out one of the reasons I'm so rested
that feels so good today is because
sometimes a mattress the mattress you
sleep on makes a huge [ __ ] difference
okay and for me it's been healing sleep
I got a call from them about a month ago
they went just through the sponsoring
the show but they wanted to send me a
match at first listen the mattress looks
like when it came um I asked my wife
what is the canoe she doesn't ask the
mattress that's how it comes we took
them the garage we sliced it open we
took the old mattress out you put this
Hilux down and often it swells up you
sleep money one two nights and it starts
molding your body and I gotta say some
it's [ __ ] tremendous
a couple bong hits a few edibles and
before you know it I'm waking up with a
half a pot roast stuck in my [ __ ]
mash you follow me
thanks to he'll asleep I'm getting the
best sleep of my [ __ ] life
personalized mattresses made in the
u.s.a listen man for guys who sleep on
your side like me it's perfect because
it cradles you in the right place is
like like mama used to hold you memory
and you a little [ __ ] [ __ ] and
mommy used to hold you and pet the back
of your hand and whether you like it's
off the firm on your back or your
stomach if you like to sleep hot helix
has a matches for you I went online and
took to that two-minute quiz and they
sent me midnight looks even the name
makes me [ __ ] sleepy this is perfect
for side sleepers like me because it
cradles you like I said and I'm gonna
let you know a little secret these
mattresses are great for giving your
lady establish you know why cuz they're
supportive you're like it's like you're
[ __ ] on a trampoline you're going all
over the place
heads are getting banged off the wall
it's tremendous I feel like I'm 21 again
and all that mattresses deliver this
ship straight to your door and they do
it totally totally contact free delivery
you said you're thinking Joey I need the
[ __ ] matches you were just talking
about being broke but at a time like
this this is when you want to buy when
prices are low right now I'm gonna give
you the [ __ ] deal of a lifetime gonna
bobble I'm gonna tell you how helix
sleep is gonna take care of you first of
all they're gonna give you uncle Joey's
100 nights sleep on on down the trial
that means you got a hundred nights to
decide whether you like it who else does
that in the industry nobody nobody
that's why I like helix so do me a favor
try out totally matches totally free and
if you don't like it take it back and
nobody knows nothing helix has a great
deal for my thought for the church
family two of hours off all mattresses
and two free pillows at helix sleep calm
slash Church that's helix sleep calm
slash church for
200 hours off and sleep tight knowing
young for Joey sent you I want to thank
my bookie Dodd AG and I want to thank
helix leap comm / Church but most
importantly I want to thank you
[ __ ] for being the best in the
world I'll see you back Wednesday
morning tip-top Magoo with our Berto
crane stay black kick this [ __ ] the
Olli
[Music]